one of the misconceptions about  tardigrades is that they are Immortal  they're actually quite delicate animals  and can be hurt and killed easily  because of their small size tardigrades  are eaten by some even bigger  single-celled organisms in this video we  managed to record a close encounter  between a tardigrade and a giant  eukaryote but this lucky little one  managed to escape and even damaged the  cell of the eukaryote in the process and  in this clip we have a happy tardigrade  waddling on one of the most dangerous  residents of the ponds of brown Hydra  hydra's tentacles are armed with  something called pneumaticists these are  like tiny harpoons that are fired upon  contact to immobilize the hydra's prey  this water bear was either very lucky or  too small to activate the nematicists  and so got away from a heartbreaking end